welcome to this video playing soft
cheese from Norway and we get a DNA game
my trans position and to transpose is
that into some kind of mm-hmm it's a bit
of a gay reversed Scandinavian or
something like that interesting Queen on
a four it makes a weird impression so
just d6 Bishop d7 things like that
shouldn't be bad huh yeah if I take it I
don't know that accelerates stuff and so
let's just drop back and try to make
some more use of that of the hook of the
Queen position so what is he doing 95 ok
ok then I'll oh-6 bishop edge for us
probably not a real solution down
you
cam threatening 94-year regardless isn't
isn't that good 94 why does he have this
this wacky quincy formal which looks
totally totally wrong maybe maybe has
that move anyway
and of course I mean absolutely every
move is played instantly oops because I
am miss dead one ah yeah hmm he took 18
seconds for that crap game poo wow wow
black resins nice and that's entirely
entirely unplayable whites opening you
just said I just found a way to lose it
quickly okay so let's just see what is
good there 97 is good for four clear
advantage any other moves I just meet
y'all together this is this is just rude
mmhmm yeah and and it's basically just
nonsense and something like that his
queen is Miss place he's got no
development it's just a whole bunch of
nonsense and I just blundered piece Jeff
assembly didn't calculate here even this
is the prolly yeah it's not great but I
had something that I could have played
at least it's a pawn but not enough
compensation of course yeah I just
didn't see Queen d7 oh yeah yeah yeahs
added that did the opening is just just
just terrible maybe the engine gives
that also as clearly bottom the Queen
has no squares yeah maybe that's better
I didn't want to take on general grounds
but he has no movie actually he has no
move what what has to play something
like he five just tossing a pawn
otherwise not see five will be basic to
trap the Queen yeah hey it doesn't help
if you
if you lose to some kindergarten tricks
okay well thank you for watching my